in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help some fresh developers find
their ideal vm configuration
well we fix things before the
performance goes stale stay tuned to
find out in flagel coin is a hot new
cryptocurrency trading startup that has
just taken the plunge into using custom
images for their VMs sadly though after
months of trying they couldn't get the
right machine type too high too low
costs all over the place but they are
not alone without the right level of
analysis profiling and benchmarking it's
really difficult to figure out if you're
paying too much for your configuration
or are throttling your performance
unknowingly as it turns out hitting the
sweet spot is really hard and involves
doing something like this firstly
discussed what your expected performance
benchmarks are for various systems from
the perspective of the clients and the
other key dependencies ie these systems
that we'll be using it number to create
a benchmark and testing suite to test io
performance CPU utilization and memory
performance for your VM then number
three start with a small machine bench
market and test the results against
those desired outcomes and if things
aren't fast enough try the next largest
machine and then finally continue this
entire process until you've found the
sweet spot now listen you've got better
things to do than worry about this
problem which is why Google compute
engine does all the heavy lifting for
you in fact it will just tell you
directly if you could be saving money on
your vm page and what configuration it
suggests using so how does GCE come up
with these recommendations compute
engine monitors the CPU and memory
utilization of running virtual machines
and makes recommendations using the last
8 days of data on standard and custom
machine types there's a lot of magic
going on here that we don't have time to
cover though so to learn more about how
to use the recommendations and how
stackdriver can help you get even better
estimates check out the article linked
in the description below and don't
forget to check out the rest of our
cloud performance Atlas content because
when it comes to performance every
millisecond counts